welcome back to new rock stars i got
bite size questions for you but don't
buy them because you can't put them in
your mouth right now damn it all right
it's from uh it's got greg w
he wants to know just straight up do the
avengers know coulson is alive
are they still like mourning him every
year
so this is a fun one that kind of delves
into the matter of cannon in the mcu
so according to joss whedon who directed
the pilot of the first uh agents of
shield episode he's the one who kind of
decided that agent coulson was coming
back but he also directed the first to
avengers movie
including age of ultron so when age of
ultron was coming out he clarified
that the avengers do not know that
coulson is alive
nick fury knows maria hill knows but the
rest of the avengers are not aware of
this
in fact there's an episode of agents of
shield when lady siff comes to visit and
they have to tell ladies
that don't tell thor because apparently
coulson's death as a martyr
was so important to bind the avengers
together
these dum-dums are gonna be like wait
he's alive
then we shouldn't be avengers anymore
right like that's gonna matter
also joss whedon has kind of clarified
that there is a slight
difference in canon between agents of
shield and the rest of the mcu now
for all intents and purposes the agents
of shield series is canon in the mcu
there's a ton of tie-ins
their timelines pretty much sync up
until the later seasons
but he has said specifically that the
truth of
the tv series is not necessarily the
truth of the cinematic universe
and to me the the biggest defining point
is kevin feige really hasn't had a ton
of oversight over agents of shield the
show
so unless it's part of kevin feige's
master plan for the cinematic universe i
don't know if it's technically canon i
mean on agency i think they eventually
got to they have an alternate timeline
in it now too and where earth is
destroyed and stuff so it definitely is
a whole
a whole other thing and obviously the
netflix shows also had their own thing
so what happens if like
agent coulson is like in a room and then
like steve rogers walks in he has to
pretend to be dead he has to his
pants
and he has to like have always been dead
yeah he has to be dead and then someone
has to be like
oh oh who talked about it we bring his
body here
and why did he now his pants we're
so sorry mr stark
oh god this is so bad still embarrassing
he has to drool and like play dead
and we know but he shouldn't drool
either he's been dead for like
eight years two dead bodies drool next
episode big question
yeah do dead bodies dream about me
the dream of a dead person is called
heaven oh my god eric
that's sacrilegious let's get that star
out of here it's breaking quarantine
so this question i love i think about
this question all the time i've seen
this question around too
so i'm asking you can magneto lift
thor's hammer
okay um well the marvel comics have
shown him both
lifting at times and not being able to
lift it at other times but
magneto is master of all metal but not
just the metal itself it's magnetic
field around the metal
so he can manipulate any metal that's
earth based
or extraterrestrial including uru which
is what mjolnir is made out of
and like shiar technology which is
another alien tech
but she she was a hottie i had to think
for her but she had weird arm things
and that made me confused are you the
child of the crystal
there are actually three types of
magnetism i looked this up there
there's ferromagnetism that applies to
the metallic
magnetic metals iron cobalt and nickel
but there's also paramagnetism and
diamagnetism and the other forms of
magnetism apply to
all objects just on a very small level
so all things have a magnetic field
around them that most of the times just
canceled out by gravity
but magneto has mastery over all forms
of magnetism
so theoretically he can manipulate any
object in the comics he's moved like
mountains he's moved trees just by like
manipulating the magnetic field around
them so it's not specific to metal
but just the fact that magneto can lift
mjolnir using its magnetic field
doesn't mean he is wielding the old name
oh but he could like throw it with the
feet he can move it he can deflect it
from attacks on him but he cannot
harness the powers of thor
the way cap did when he lifted the air
but he can pretty much
mess with it yeah he can you know just
kind of keep it right out of his reach
yeah i'm proud of us for not making a
sexual magnetism joke
or did we but before i continue thank
you to bang energy for sponsoring this
video
every can of bang is 16 ounces and it
contains
300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes really good with over 20
different flavors to choose from
one of those great flavors is peach
mango and how to describe peach mango
well imagine a major league baseball
pitcher throwing a peach in your mouth
followed by a curveball mango
two bites of delicious fruit with a ton
of energy
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
and fitness supplements all kinds of
stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25 okay this next question
comes from third ward tx guy donnie
it's a very good question about
cyclops's
very effective ray bans basically he
wants to know how is it that
the rays that come from uh cyclops's
eyes they can like just they can level
mountains and they can
cut people and have to do all kinds of
things but they don't just like knock
his sunglasses off his face
how does that work okay so uh scott
summers's civilian sunglasses are made
out of the same material that his optic
blast lenses when he's like in superhero
mode it's made out of this material
called
ruby quartz which in real life is
actually very brittle
it would fall apart but at the time in
the 60s when stanley was developing
these characters
like lasers were a thing so he's just
kind of like yeah one
will be able to shoot lasers out of his
eyes but people believe that the ruby
quartz
um limits the light that comes into his
eyes to just the red part of the
spectrum
so scott summers when he walks around he
absorbs
solar energy through his body and that's
what he converts into the optic blast
but they're saying that the the reason
why that's just not happening every time
you know he opens his eyes behind the
ruby courts is his cones are only being
activated
on the red scale from the the solar
light that's coming in however later
canon has further clarified
that scott's eyes open portals to
another dimension of chaotic
concussiveness laser energy optic energy
so every time he opens his eyes
he is opening those gateways those
portals to other dimensions
to the optic blast yeah but the
uh the sunglasses and the normal lens
that he has as cyclops
are made out of the same material that
prevents that from happening so it's
true what they say the eyes are a
gateway to a laser hell dimension
they do say that good job good job
hey uh i'm eric boss you can find me at
eavos
anywhere on social media you can follow
this guy at the molina
in the same places and follow new
rockstars on socials and hey
yeah you know subscribe to me rockstars
uh here on youtube share this show
uh we're making content during the
apocalypse
maybe some of your friends might want to
watch it yes see you next week
bye stay safe
[Music]
you